[Applause]
thank you for being here thank you for
having me yeah i'm so glad
everyone more famous was busy right now
so
great this is you i really wanted you
here thank you so much
it's so exciting uh you know first of
all i also want to congratulate you not
just for being uh
you know following the nutcracker lady
but uh
since i last saw you you got engaged i
did i'm engaged to be married
thank you very much now have you ever
thought about
getting married or your wedding or
anything like that never happened when i
realized is my girlfriend has literally
thought about getting married since the
time her brain
could operate properly and i've been
thinking about getting married from like
the second i asked her to marry me until
right now and i never thought about it
ever before that at all
and and now we have all these
conversations about it and i kind of
like
find myself having opinions about like
what centerpieces should look like and
i'm like
what am i doing i don't care about any
of this stuff at all like i could
honestly give a [ __ ] and uh and but
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you don't seem like the most romantic
guy so how did you pop the questions
well i uh when i got i had all these
elaborate plans you know and when i got
the ring i
it was so nerve-wracking having this
ring like it literally i felt like i had
like someone to give me like a truckload
of heroin to hold on to like
it's like watch this man just watch it
and like
i i felt like the like feds were gonna
kick in my door at any second like i was
just
so nervous when i got it i'm like i
couldn't have a conversation with my
like
my girlfriend all i could think was this
ring like don't mention lord of the
rings don't say anything about a ring
like
it was it was horrible and so i had all
these plans but like the day i got the
ring literally the second i got it
i walked right upstairs to where she was
to propose to her but she was uh
she was in our closet changing and she
was literally only in her underpants and
her boobs were out
and uh and i had i had already kind of
started i was like oh man her boobs are
out like that's not part of the plan
like
was not i i i didn't picture like this
and i know she didn't picture it like
this like
no little girl is like it'll happen in a
closet with my titties out like
it's not
that's not how you picture it no we got
that word exactly so uh
but i figured we're just going but i
figured the only appropriate thing was
to was to place the ring on her nipple
actually
[Applause]
man that was this is
now uh i don't want to make any
assumptions about you i know you
i don't say i know you better than uh
than a lot of people in the business
but i'm guessing that you were
disappointed that proposition 19 failed
i'm just that's an issue
i was the marijuana proposition yeah
but the good news is literally anyone on
earth can get a medical marijuana card
that's the thing that i couldn't
understand is that in this state people
were so it was such a big question
will they legalize marijuana or not and
uh it looks like it's
fairly easy thing to do you get a
medical marijuana i have a medical
marijuana prescription
uh personally i went in and i told they
they said what do you need it for and i
said
i have a very specific ailment it's
called i ain't got no weed on me right
now
and they i ain't got no weed
that was how i worded it and uh the lady
said we actually have just the thing for
that
and uh and uh
she wrote me well it's funny actually
because i thought she'd just write me a
prescription like it'd be easy but she
actually started like taking my blood
pressure and stuff like that i was like
what is happening right now like
whose benefit is this for and then i
started getting worried like what if the
weed doctor actually finds something
wrong with me like that would be because
i
i actually see her more than my actual
doctor i think so
that would be weird you've got a very
rare blood disorder exactly
you need weed exactly
well you're you're happy it all worked
out for you either way you're
oh man the uh what's about the green
you're
you're the green hornet is your next
project it is and this is coming out
very soon it's coming out in january 14
2011.
no i don't want i love you i'm a big fan
of yours
but and then i heard that you got this
you're the star of an action movie yes
and seth rogen is not a guy who i think
of immediately as being someone who
kicks ass
no is that is that a fair thing to say i
don't pick you kicking ass i don't kick
much i actually did karate when i was a
kid though and i took classes at the
jewish community center and i think
i learned how to kick some ass and uh
the jewish community i did at the jccc
the vj the vancouver jewish community
center and
and i i and i kind of got in shape a
little bit if matthew mcconaughey looked
like this he'd murder himself i can tell
you that
he would literally kill himself but for
me this is pretty awesome i gotta say
what moves did you learn at the
vancouver jewish community there's a lot
of guilt-driven maneuvers
[Laughter]
which can paralyze you it only works on
other jewish people it's the problem
no it works on catholics too trust me
it's a wide berth there